Don't hate on the new iPhone. Don't hate
on the new iPhone. I mean, come on,
Lionus. It's got [music] everything that
you like. A giant HDR folding display, a
desktop class CPU with phase change
cooling, uncompromising commitment to
durability with both water resistance
and exotic structural reinforcements,
not to mention the triumphant return of
Touch ID.
>> Praise Jobs.
>> Indeed. Hallelujah.
So, why do I have to convince myself not
to hate on it? Well, how about the minor
fact that I've already seen this movie?
As someone who's been dailying foldables
since long before they got actually good
and cool, I've learned a lot about what
works and what doesn't work. And in my
opinion, Apple made a critical mistake
that stands to set the entire industry
on a path that makes these devices
flashier and cooler, but less usable
dayto-day. We're going to get to that
later. Along with the new watches, the
iPhone 18 Pro and Pro Max, and near and
dear to my heart, a really nice upgrade
to the AirPods family that somehow isn't
going to cost you extra. Just like I
never charge extra for a segue to our
sponsor, Threat Locker. As you deploy AI
into your workforce, every AI agent that
improves productivity or efficiency also
brings risk. Threat Locker allows you to
put controls around what your AI tools
can do and access. Learn more about how
Threat Locker can help you at the link
below.
Bloomberg suggests that Tim Cook first
became excited about the foldable form
factor after a few trips to Asia in
2020. An excitement that after years of
rumors finally paid off just days after
his replacement by John Turnis, the
former vice president of hardware
engineering who oversaw this product's
creation. And what a creation story it
is. In a one more thing segment that
felt like it went on longer than some
entire Apple keynotes, Apple outlined
everything that they changed to make
this the thinnest iPhone ever with
unprecedented performance and a
virtually creaseless inner screen. So,
what are all the things they changed?
Well, all of them. Starting with the
screen. To get the flattest possible
appearance on the inner display, Apple
employed a refined nanoexture coating to
reduce glossy reflections on the crease.
We've seen some early hands-on footage
from other reviewers who are at the
event, and I got to say, looks pretty
good. Not nothing, but a lot less than
something. They also built each display
from a 10 layer stack that can shift
like the pages of a book to help reduce
bend stress over time, which combined
with a sophisticated hinge that gets
tolerance matched to each housing using
AI could help the iPhone to avoid that
classic, "Wow, yeah, that sure looks
great today. Um, talk to me in a few
months when it smiles at you every time
you open it." Overall, it seems like
Apple has taken the best of what Samsung
is doing, like the titanium sub layer
that we first saw on the ZFold 8,
[music]
and added that little bit of extra
polish. Apple claims that their inner
screen hits 30,000 nits of brightness
and uses wide-angle OLED pixels, notably
ones from the Apple Watch to help
improve clarity from even extreme
viewing angles. Another fine piece of
Apple forthought, both the 5.4 in outer
and 7.6 6 in inner displays feature the
same classic 1: 1.4 aspect ratio, which
Apple hopes will make things feel more
consistent when you open and close the
Duo and help avoid adding two more
screen layouts for app developers to
just this one product. Oh, on that note,
they've also published some helpful
videos already guiding developers on how
to best make use of this newfound screen
real estate. This kind of thing really
goes a long way towards creating a
consistent feeling experience. Even with
a folding design, Apple has tried to
focus on durability with a reinforced
hinge, titanium braces that go across
the frame, and reinforcements on the
antenna lines. All of this is packed
into a titanium frame, which I got to
say, it sounds like this thing is built
like a tank. Thing about tanks, though,
they're kind of heavy. At 254 g, it
weighs a whopping 25% more than the
competing Galaxy Zfold 8. So, with that
said, there are clear benefits to
Apple's approach, like going from IP48
to IP68 water and dust resistance and
getting a hinge design that can hold in
between positions so you can watch
movies like this or type like this or
have the world's most expensive alarm
clock like this. Okay, the last one
obviously a bit of a joke, but in all
seriousness, it is a feature that I use
at the gym on my Fold 7 a lot. Not
everything is roses though. While the
front glass uses Apple's kind of
legendary ceramic shield too, the back
cover uses the last gen version and
Apple isn't sharing exactly what the
inner display is made of beyond that it
is a custom polymer. So, our best guess
from other foldables is that it's likely
to be a little more prone to micro
scratches than you might have gotten
used to over the last couple of
generations. Personally though, I don't
see this as a huge deal because 99% of
my micro scratches are from debris in my
pockets. And your foldable doesn't go
into your pocket like this. It goes in
like that. [music] Another huge win on
the Duo is the lack of a hole punch or a
notch in the inner screen. It's got a
selfie camera, but Apple has placed it
under the display using tech that in
classic Apple fashion, we've seen used,
but not perfected on the Android side of
the walled garden. I'm really interested
to see what advancements, if any, Apple
has made here, and I'm excited to see
the rest of the industry push to catch
up and eliminate these eyes [music] once
and for all. The company's spec sheet is
relatively bare about this camera. They
say it records in 1080p, has ultra
stabilization and center stage for video
calls and wide color capture, but that's
about it. And they seem to be
positioning it as more of a FaceTime
camera than anything else, which makes
sense since the selfie camera on the
front display is going to be much
better. And since you can unfold the
thing anyway, you can always use the
main rear cameras as your selfie
shooters, assuming that you put in the
100 hours minimum that I assume it takes
to get as dextrous as this guy. Man, I
am not into the placement of the touch
sensitive camera button here. And since
we're on the subject, I'm not into the
removal of the action button either. As
for the other cameras, these appear to
be minor upgrades compared to last year,
which is to say that it should have a
best-in-class selfie shooter with that
awesome on the-fly aspect ratio
adjustment alongside pretty much the
same great 48 megapixel main camera from
the iPhone Air and the same ultra wide
lens and sensor combo that the company
is still using on the [music] 18 Pro.
The real upgrade on the Duo is going to
be on the software side where you can
now use photographic styles 3 which
allows you to add grain and texture to
your photos if you want that look. Cool.
You'll save all kinds of money compared
to buying a 2000 era digital camera on
marketplace. I guess really the bigger
camera upgrades are going to be on the
iPhone 18 Pro, which we're going to get
into later. First, the rest of the Duo's
hardware, which includes two
rechargeable lithium-ion batteries that
Apple says will last for around 24 hours
of typical use. though, it's hard to
tell how that's going to work out in the
real world since Apple is anticipating
50% usage between the inner screen and
the outer screen. And guys, I ain't met
anybody who uses their inner screen
anywhere near 50% of the time. And on
top of that, Apple also acknowledged
that they retoled their battery testing
and validation procedures this year. So,
it's going to be a bit hard to know how
this compares to previous iPhones until
we get to test it ourselves. using the
more standard streaming video playback
metric. The company says we can expect
about 37 hours when folded and 26 hours
when unfolded. To top up that battery,
you can finally use a fast charger since
it supports a 60W USB input or higher
apparently, whatever that means. And on
the wireless side, it's still got Magg
Safe, too, which can do
>> 25 W
>> charging and will of course lock in
conveniently with your existing MagSafe
accessories. All of this is powered by
the new Apple A20 Pro SOC, a two
nanometer chip with [music] two desktop
class super cores and four efficiency
cores for a total of six on top of a
better GPU than ever by a long shot
apparently and [music] more neural
accelerators, including a second 16 core
AI engine that Apple mentioned more than
once should make this new chip very well
suited to running third-party local AI
models. a use case that personally I
[music] am really really excited about
as I reach my tipping point for how much
of my personal information I want in the
cloud or also I guess you could just use
the neural engine to generate genojis.
Moving on, this has got to be my
favorite part. Apple actually called me
up personally about this and they said,
"You know what, Lionus?
You were right about Touch ID. We were
wrong. Also, you're much taller than
Marquez."
>> Yeah, okay. That never happened. But
what did is Apple dropped Face ID on the
iPhone Duo in favor of Touch ID built
into the lock button. And as someone who
has always preferred my biometric
authentication to be built into the
button that I already had to touch
anyway, I see this as an absolute win.
With that said, I know that some users
do prefer Face ID, and I'd love to see
Apple bring that back to future Duos as
well, just to give users more choice.
Always a good thing. Finally, like other
modern iPhones, you get access to
emergency SOS features, Wi-Fi 7, Siri
AI, and thanks to the new C2 modem,
millimeter wave 5G. We also get eSIM,
but unlike [clears throat] other modern
iPhones, it's eSIM only globally, which
could be annoying in some markets.
Finally, finally, Apple says support for
the Apple Pencil USBC is coming soon.
And there's lots to love about the
software, including this glorious
transition from the inner screen to the
outer screen. This cute little feature
that helps keep toddlers looking into
the lens, a tent mode that uses standby
to show you photos, widgets, or the
time, and enhanced multitasking so you
can use two apps at once, or multiple
instances of the same app, or even tap
the divider between two apps to pin them
together, making it easier to go back to
them. iPhone Duo sits at the top of
Apple's price ladder at $2,000,
but given the current climate,
it could have been worse. And I have no
doubt that this thing is going to be a
smash hit out of the gate, pouring
hundreds of millions of dollars into
Apple's already stuffed coffers, which I
guess finally gets me to the part that I
am unhappy about, cuz everything so far
was pretty good, wasn't it? the fact
that I believe Apple is pushing the
entire industry in the wrong direction
for aspect ratio. I know that you guys
tuned into this video so that you didn't
have to sit through Apple's hour plus
long version of it, but still [music]
at least give it a scrub through. Okay,
do it. You notice that? Do it again. Do
you notice they don't once show the
iPhone with the keyboard open on the
outer display? Why do you think that is?
That's because they know the lack of
vertical screen real estate means that
whether it's vertical video or text or
just plain navigating the web, you're
going to end up feeling like you're
using a BlackBerry 8300. Apple has taken
steps to minimize this effect, moving
the dock to the side and combining the
status icons. And who knows, maybe I'm
going to discover that just like with
AirPods taking away my wire and my 3 and
12 mm jack, I just need to get with the
times using my voice to interact with my
phone rather than my keyboard. But
[music] to me, for now, the way that
Apple glossed over this issue is a tacid
acknowledgement that is going to be a
real problem for some users and may lead
to some returns. And only time will tell
if this is going to be a holding it
wrong iPhone 4 level of returns or a
this product is cancelled vision pro
level of returns. Let's move on to
AirPods and Apple watches before we
unpack the iPhone that more people are
actually going to buy, the iPhone 18
Pro. AirPods 5. These I like. They're an
upgraded version of the company's open
earphones. But this year, both the
cheaper $130 skew, and the more
expensive skew has active noise
cancelling, which already worked better
than I expected given their lack of a
silicone seal last generation, and now
is apparently even better. But wait,
there's more. The expensive model isn't
so expensive anymore at just $150 to get
the AirPods Fives and a wireless
charging case and the ability to slide
your finger up and down the stems to
change volume. The more expensive model
also gets a 5h hour battery life rating
with&c compared to just four on the
cheaper option. More value and more
better. Man, I freaking love AirPods.
Apple Watch though I could kind of not
care that much about. But hey, for those
who are into them, we did get some
exciting upgrades along with a really
weird one. To start, Series 12 comes in
a few new colors and materials. Neat.
The aluminum models are still cheaper
than the other materials, but they got
upgraded this year with ceramic shield 2
cover glass, which should help you be
able to wear them for even longer
without scratching them up. The titanium
and ceramic models still have sapphire
front crystals, which is pretty much
unscratchable if you really want a watch
for the long haul. And if you're into
the watch Ultra, you'll be happy to know
that it got a slight battery bump this
year to around 50 hours of regular use
that can be boosted to 84 when you're
using it in low power mode. Inside all
the watches, you'll find the new S11
chip, which unlocks new audio
intelligence features. These are the
kind of weird thing I mentioned earlier.
This new tech records what's happening
around you, allowing for users to double
tap the digital crown on the watch and
get a recap of what was said in the last
15 seconds or so. or and this is
apparently a separate feature, [music]
it can take notes on your conversations
throughout the day and then give you a
highle recap later. Apple says this is
secure and then you can save these
conversations in the new Siri app if you
want to revisit them later. Um,
I'll let you guys decide what you think.
Uh, building off this feature though,
the watch can also alert you to specific
sounds like a doorbell or a crying baby.
Okay, these ones I actually kind of like
and are bound to be pretty helpful for
people who are hard of hearing or just
ADHD.
Sorry, what were we talking about? Ah,
yes. The final audio intelligence
feature uses Shazam to automatically
detect what songs are playing nearby.
Might not sound like that big of a deal,
but it's been a killer feature on Pixel
phones for years, and people freaking
love it over there. For the
fitness-minded, Apple has upgraded the
sensor array on the new watches to make
them more accurate, and they can now
track HRV, which lets the Apple Watch
act more like a Whoop band or a modern
Garmin by tracking your rest and
recovery. Combined with a redesigned
health app and a more clear-cut
readiness score, this should help make
the Apple Watch a more fully featured
workout companion [music] than ever
before. Which brings us finally to the
iPhone 18 Pro and Pro Max. New colors
will be highlights to people like my
pre-teen nephew who noticed that I had a
current gen iPhone recently just because
it was a color that was exclusive to
that generation. I was like, "How do you
know this?" Um, but he did. And moving
on to the stuff that actually matters to
me, we get the same A20 Pro chip as the
iPhone Duo. So, I'm expecting impressive
performance and a main camera assembly,
which has been improved this year with a
sixb blade variable aperture. Apple says
this should result in better lowlight
photography, but until we can figure out
just how much larger, if at all, the
main sensor is. Um, we can't assume that
the gains will be as large as some
people are hoping. When you go into the
camera app on the 18 Pro, you'll be able
to choose between four aperture settings
though, ranging from f1.8 to f4. And the
camera also has the new grain and
texture controls as part of the new
photographic styles engine that we
mentioned when we were talking about the
Duo. Honestly, what will be more
interesting will be to see if Apple
makes them backwards compatible with the
iPhone 16 and 17 series. But
then why would you buy an 18 Pro?
>> Little boy dream.
>> To keep up with the new manual aperture,
Apple has also retoled the main camera
app to give it more pro tools like white
balance and shutter speed controls.
These were things that you could do in
many third party camera apps, but hey,
it's nice to see Apple finally get back
to their classic Sherlocking like they
used to do. On the flip side of that,
the company mentioned that it is making
the APK for the variable aperture
public. So, third party cameras will
also be able to control that. So, maybe
not full Sherlock. If you're into mobile
gaming, Apple has also upgraded the
vapor chamber in the 18 Pro series to be
three times larger, claiming 40% better
thermal dissipation over the iPhone 17
Pro. That is a pretty big deal because
peak performance means pretty much
nothing to people who are gaming for
long periods. And it's that sustained
performance that matters. With all that
said, the biggest upgrade to me is the
battery. We don't know the empirical
milliamp sizes yet, but Apple claims
that we should expect up to 33 hours of
video streaming playback on the Pro and
up to 40 hours on the Pro Max. I mean,
that is some next generation binging
enablement. We also get a slightly
smaller dynamic island. Not as good as
an in-creen camera, but I'll take small
W's when I can get them. And that should
be about it. Of course, every win these
days, though, feels like it comes with
some losses. And in this case, we're
talking a loss of $100. Apple quietly
not only increased the prices of their
new generation iPhones, but also
increased the prices of the last gen
phones that are sticking around in the
lineup by $100. So, it turns out even
Apple is not immune to Ramageddon. As
you're deploying AI into your workforce,
you know that every AI agent that you
bring in to improve productivity or
efficiency also brings its own risks.
That's where Threat Locker comes in.
Threat Locker has pre-built community
policies for safely deploying AI agents
like claude code and codecs into your
environment. Because if you don't have
the proper guardrails up, your agent may
be accessing resources without you
knowing. Threat Locker allows you to put
controls around what your AI tools can
do, such as what files, networking
resources, and applications it can
interact with. It also gives you the
visibility into what they're accessing
and executing. Learn more about how you
can set boundaries and choose what
access your AI agents have so they can
operate safely within your organization
today at the link in the video
description. Also, check out their blog
that details these readyto deploy
policies that can be put into place to
help safeguard your teams. That'll be
linked below, too. Anyway, thanks for
watching. If you guys are in a folding
kind of mood, make sure you check out my
unboxing over on our short circuit
channel of the Galaxy ZF Fold 8. Spoiler
alert, it went from ick to to eh.